tell us how you make decisions when the
previous CEO is still around and
obviously there is you know you have to
work together and cooperate yeah Lea and
I have a great relationship we really
did a great job when we were together
dividing out responsibilities and today
I lead a lot of those all the decisions
in the company
and she spends time thinking with me as
a thought partner on long-term strategic
issues and it's great
Stacey um you spent nearly a decade at
Google with Sheryl Sandberg what have
you brought from that experience to
TaskRabbit I think there's two big
things I brought from my Google
experience one is just that scarcity
brings clarity and you know focusing on
the right things you'll get to great
outcomes and TaskRabbit has been
successful in quadrupling our business
last year because of that focus also in
building a great leadership team I felt
a great team around me and it's one of
the reasons why I love working at the
company we create meaning we create
economic impact and I get to work with
an amazing team yeah how concerned are
you at the the Silicon Valley economy we
were talking yesterday about Dropbox
potentially going public at some point
after there had been a down round or
funds had been marking down their value
of their investments and its valuation
is 10 billion dollar company was in
question how in that environment do you
raise more funding because I believe
you're trying well in our space I think
the future is bright when you look at
the sharing economy we pioneer this
economy back in 2008 and there's been so
much positive energy and a lot of people
seem to think that the social movement
is sort of lost this meaning but it
really it really hasn't we've really
created a new place for people to think
about the assets that they have using
their time effectively and create value
and think about the value that they have
so people are living a new consciousness
of freedom and empowerment so I think
our space is bright the future's bright
for TaskRabbit and the sharing economy
overall yeah but you've also had a lot
of pushback especially when you
categorize workers as contractors and
not employees how important is this
distinction to your company's bottom
line and how do you deal with the risk
of legal action
our tasker's are everything to us
we built this community because the
client to use TaskRabbit
appreciate and value most the quality of
the experience that they have
we have over 50,000 registered tasker's
who come and love the flexibility of
work they get to set their own hourly
rates they make on average thirty five
dollars an hour and over fifteen
thousand people come to TaskRabbit every
month wanting a task on TaskRabbit
so we see this as a new way of work in
fact it's a new normal that I like to
think of as a future of work and at the
core of it we're creating everyday work
for everyday people we're using
TaskRabbit every day to pay one two
three major bills every month and it's
fantastic talk to us about competition
from the likes of handy which I know has
been having a little bit of difficulty
you also have competition from uber and
Amazon given that TaskRabbit is is
really everything for everybody our
competition really is people choosing to
do it themselves we want like every
client to think of TaskRabbit when they
need something done around their home
whether they get their house clean or
they need a handyman and right now we're
just trying to be top of mind for them
we don't really see the competition as
other companies it really is just you
doing yourselves and when you think of a
hint needing a handyman or a cleaner we
want you to think of TaskRabbit as your
everyday brand for on-demand home
service and you plan to be profitable by
the end of the year but are you raising
funding well we're always everybody's
always raising funny in these startup
that's bent your funding should be
thinking about raising funding but
profitability will give us the freedom
to choose how we want to grow and how we
want to expand and we believe that we
will have the opportunity to do that
next year